los casos de kobe 19 alcanzan cifras
récord en eeuu
impulsados por el avance de la variante
o micro aunque según los centros de
control y prevención de enfermedades ya
representa el 95 por ciento de los
contagios y el presidente joe biden ha
lanzado una advertencia para quienes
insisten en no recibir la vacuna
saben preocúpense por omicron pero no se
alarmen y si usted no está vacunado
tiene motivos para estar alarmado muchos
de ustedes padecerán enfermedad severa
si tienen como 19 y no están vacunados
algunos morirán morirán innecesariamente
son muta e indulta las largas filas para
obtener una prueba se multiplican por
todo el país desde el inicio de las
fiestas navideñas el país ha registrado
un aumento del 50% en las
hospitalizaciones por kobe 19 new yersey
ha sido uno de los estados más golpeados
en una semana el número de pacientes
hospitalizados aumentó en un 76%
tenemos más personas en el hospital hoy
que en cualquier momento del año pasado
y la mayor cantidad desde principios de
mayo del año 2020 y tanto en este estado
como en el resto del país la vuelta a la
educación presencial es uno de los
principales temas en discusión en
sintonía con el deseo del presidente joe
biden filmar cia seguro que new yersey
no se cerrarán las escuelas permítanme
ser claro actualmente no tenemos ninguna
intención ni plan de cerrar nuestras
escuelas no tenemos ningún deseo de
volver a la enseñanza a distancia
entre tanto el sindicato de profesores
de chicago votó el martes porque la
capital de illinois sea la primera en
cerrar las escuelas en este inicio de
año